hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
May is upon us which brings more video
game releases if you haven't already
heard the headline act of the month The
Last of Us part 2 is delayed to give us
time to fight off this real-world
pandemic before venturing into another
one with Joel and Ellie anyway let's not
focus on what we aren't getting our
hands on let's look at five games
available to buy in May 20 2001 I've
also found a free-to-play game to give
us a little variation in lock down let's
do this I'm starting with minecraft
dungeons we chatted about this last
month but now we have a release date May
26th minecraft dungeons removes the open
world survival elements we all know and
love and replaces that with a dungeon
crawling a can slash adventure the main
building block of dungeons is law using
the characters and mobs you know and
adding backstories and rules to their
existence
unlike most dungeon crawlers minecraft
dungeons does not force classes upon you
instead we enchant
our equipment to adapt our play style
for example your ball can be modded to
ricochet between enemies and your sword
can wield ice fire and even Thor's
lightning powers each time we level up
we grab yet another enchantment point
which keeps us upgrading and changing
our weapons constantly on top of that we
have artifacts which adds over-the-top
abilities to our characters which are
essential for handling huge waves of
enemies missions are selected by
difficulty which in turn rewards better
loot so do you stick with your current
combat level or do you go in over your
head in the hopes of nabbing a piece of
equipment which will make you a
blockheaded god let me know your
thoughts of this one minecraft dungeons
drops on May 26 on PC ps4 switch and
Xbox one
[Music]
so here's the free game I found for this
month and it's actually out right now
this is don't even think a horror take
on battle royale I first showed you this
last year as the devs tested it out in
North American servers and I'll be
honest it wasn't great back then well
now they believe the game is full
release ready and is now available in
Europe - don't even think attempts to
cross battle royale with dead by
daylight here's how firstly there are
two classes humans and get this
werewolves humans are the military types
you've seen in all be our games jump out
of a plane loot and eliminate other
players and stay alive to win you know
how all that already works but here's
the gimmick the werewolf class when
playing as the dark minion you'll begin
as a hulking grunt and you'll only be
able to use melee weapons as they take
out other players and find downed
players the werewolf within them needs
to feed and suddenly the player will
morph into a rapid werewolf who is a
beast in all meanings of the word the
game then becomes a Marines versus
monsters scenario and carnage usually
ensues season two has just kicked off in
game bringing a new map and new where
beings including a we're cat embrace
your inner furry maybe don't even think
is out now and is completely free but it
will try and get your cash with battle
passes and microtransactions if this
gives you something different to play
during lockdown then this video has
served its purpose I hope you enjoy it
[Music]
again which I didn't cover last month
needs a little love right now because
I've been playing it all month on ps4
and it's great and on the last day of
April it's out on pc and xbox one Call
of Duty modern warfare 2 remastered I
won't patronize you you know everything
about Cod games already but this
remaster is a thing of beauty
Sony primarily paid for the game to be
remastered so that's why we got it a
month early the remaster though has such
good updates the visuals are staggering
the missions feel perfect you need this
in your life if you like Call of Duty
you gotta get this and I'll be covering
the Easter eggs in this masterpiece this
week the only downside is the lack of
multiplayer but those maps will be found
in the current modern warfare game man
these naming conventions are weird
anyway just want to say how great it is
it's really good really good at this
point I planned on talking about
wasteland 3 but that's been delayed I
planned on talking about new worlds but
that's been delayed I planned on talking
about Ironman VR but that's been delayed
basically this month has been
annihilated so let's focus on a few
smaller games which don't get the
limelight like this one maneater a game
in which you play as a shark and
terrorize everyone and I mean everyone
human beings turtles and even other
sharks the premise is pretty funny we
play as a baby bull shark who must take
revenge on the legendary shark hunter
scaly Pete who hunted down our shark
mother and disfigured our shark face
forever it's hitting you in the fields
isn't it I know I feel it too with this
with seven regions to explore in an open
world and to keep things interesting
there's narration like it takes place in
a documentary program it's strange but
kind of cool if this is your thing look
out for it from May 22nd on ps4 Xbox PC
and it works on the switch to GG another
noteworthy game this month is actually a
remaster of Saints Row 3 ok some of you
will be more impressed than others but
if you are old enough to remember that
masterpiece of a game this gives you a
chance to revisit that with updated
lighting and tweaks to everything in the
game the third Streets
have gone from street gang to celebrity
but now the syndicate criminal family
are ready to fight back if you've never
played a saint's row game think of it
like GTA gone insane this one is another
one that drops on May 22nd on ps4 and
Xbox one so may isn't the shining beacon
of video game brilliance we all thought
it would be but take solace in that
all those delayed games will release in
the future hopefully one day anyway the
games on PS Plus this month are far
better but I can't talk about those just
yet
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade thanks
for your time please think about doing
the like and subscribe thing it really
helps especially in lockdown thanks for
your time see ya
[Music]